less than 48 hours it will be national
tequila day and if you're looking to
celebrate we're going to show you how to
make the perfect margarita joining us
now is henry martinez the bar manager at
tacos and tequila which is inside palace
station thank you for joining us buddy
thank you for having me how many
different tequilas do you guys have uh
we're out where it's about almost 100.
okay yeah we're changing every day we're
adding some we're kind of seeing what
works what doesn't work and then we're
always uh you know sprucing up the
tequila menu you're on top of the
tequila game i'm a vodka guy and some
people say oh vodka's vodka that's not
the case when it comes to tequila it's
tequila tequila what's the best what's
your favorite i mean it really depends
on your preference you know they have
the blanco which is basically just
straight not distilled at all not aged
then it goes into representatives where
it's aged a little bit more and then
anejo which is aged longer which gives
it the more oaky or kind of
almost like a how a bourbon would be you
know in a cask or something like that so
it depends what you like you know for
beginners i guess usually just go with
the straight clear shots and then you
just develop them just go and then just
get down there okay what goes into
making the perfect margarita well let me
show you
how about it henry all right let's do it
so what are you doing so let's start
with our glass get some ice in there
and you guys have too as you keep making
the tequila what's happening on sunday
at the restaurant so it's national
national tequila day
so we are uh
serving we're doing with every purchase
of a shot you get one of these little
skeleton shots as well you keep making
them we gotta get some drinks you keep
making it
look at this so i i do a shot and then
purchase of any shot no matter what it
is you get one of those fancy little
skeleton shotguns as many shot glasses
as possible on sunday that works for
each shot you get a shot glass walk home
with 12 of them just make sure you take
uh ride share when you get this so
here's our haha it's a small batch
tequila it's a reposado we do about one
and a half ounces of that and where's
this room
uh all tequila's from actual like
jalisco mexico so tequila actually has
to be made there
uh anywhere else in the world it's not
you can't call it to kill it it has to
come from jalisco tequila mexico perfect
all right a little bit knowledge for you
45 seconds here what else is going into
the perfect margarita at home as well we
do a little bit of the
fresh
made margarita mix and as you're pouring
it in here you guys also have a brunch
on sunday as well we do yes
and it is
playing there as well yeah it's a
mariachi brunch
we do a half price appetizer buy one get
one uh top shelf margaritas
and then
watch henry how long have you been
working in las vegas uh been about 12
years now
yeah
low key flex all from this that's all
for the flex
stirred all right
there we go awesome man
this is going to be good on sunday
national tequila day perfect margarita
you guys make it right there
should i do a taste test absolutely hold
on not yet
do our little magic float magic
this is what makes it a top shelf when
you
very similar yeah sure yep this oh this
gives it this case of that this gives it
the reason for me to take a ride share
home tonight i'll give it a give a taste
all right
delicious thank you so much henry enjoy
national tequila